foreign
okay so I'm super jazzed today we're
going to talk about
something that's near and dear to my
heart and it's one of the top questions
I get asked all the time on the on the
Instagrams on the Facebooks on the phone
calls emails however people can get a
hold of me my friends ask
supplements supplements which
supplements should I take why should I
take them we don't even need to be
taking all the questions about
supplements and normally on these type
of shows the conversations get highly
highly technical so I'm Gonna Leave the
the technical aspects of all of this to
the Andrew hubermans and the Peter
Attias of the world much smarter guys
who are med school professors and
medical doctors
I'm going to talk about supplements
today
um in a way that I can understand it and
I'm not the sharpest tool in the shed
and then I'm going to
let you know about a new partnership I
got that is going to
change you and your family so
here's the deal people take supplements
for a million different reasons some of
them are because of fads right some
study on the John test show will come
out or some study on Yahoo News will
come out and then everyone will will be
like oh I got to take this some of them
uh some YouTuber is like bro you should
has some Financial stake in his own
supplement line
um and he wants you to to take all these
things or your DACA doctor recommends it
and doctors sometimes get a swath panel
meaning
they just say you know what you should
have some vitamin C and some vitamin D
and some zinc and then people go off to
Walgreens and they or they'll go to
Walmart and they'll buy the cheapest
thing they can find or they'll find
um the brown bottle that looks like it's
like ancient medicine it's like some
kind of potion and that looks like it's
going to be more like yeah
um and they take that stuff some people
take supplements because there's
possibly less nutrients in food now that
we're genetically modifying whatever and
you got on that rabbit hole
um they have more chronically stressful
Lifestyles pollution all kinds of
different reasons um some people take
them for training advantages or sporting
advantages or to help augment or
um augment
um neurological function right cognition
uh smart drugs they call them nootropics
um so here's the thing you need to know
about supplements the industry is the
Wild Wild West
the number of studies that have come
back showing we just like the third
party testing groups will go grab
supplements off random grocery store
shelves off local corner store shelves
off Walmart shelves whatever and they
will test them and the number of
different
uh chemical compounds they find in these
things how it says you know it's got a
500 000 you know
milligrams of vitamin D in there and
there's eight milligrams right like
whatever
it's the Wild West it's not even like
the FDA which we all know is just
knocking out of the park the last few
years it's it's simply
like make it up as you go and it is
causing people to take the wrong things
it's causing professional athletes to
test positive for things that they're
they didn't intentionally ingest
um it's causing people to waste a ton of
money
and most supplements I'm sad to say are
trash trash they're no good they're no
good
um
years ago years ago
um
I was introduced to a company called
Thorne
t-h-o-r-n-e and their promise was we are
the purest supplements on the planet
and we have multiple third-party testers
and they
um have Partnerships with the Mayo
Clinic with companies all over the world
saying we are not just going to put
labels on things so and and have you
trust us we're going to have third party
testers run studies and they are going
to show you that what we say is true and
then they became the athlete supplement
of choice because athletes could take
them and trust that what they were
taking was actually in the supplement
and they weren't going to test positive
for some sort of anabolic agent that
they weren't allowed to be having
um so I started years ago
taking Thorn supplements
here's why I do it
um a couple of reasons one I've had
multiple consults with doctors over the
years and I've always worked pretty
closely with doctors and I'm into woo
stuff and all that but
um I run pretty hard and y'all heard me
say my wife says man you're a lot
um but I put my body through it
um
so when I run stress tests my stress
biomarkers are very high they're not as
clean as they should be
um this week I wrote this down this week
I'll be in three different states
multiple time zones last week I spoke to
uh three uh three different of speaking
of uh speaking engagements for hundreds
of people at one corporate event and
then flew to Los Angeles for another
event I've got a writing deadline going
I've got two little kids that I'm
running around with I have a battle of
the bands heavy metal event this weekend
that's gonna be in front of a couple
thousand people then I get on a plane to
go to a funeral in another state like
I'm all over the place
and so I run hard and that's just I'm on
this end of the spectrum but before I
was doing that I was just a parent of
two little kids trying to get my job
done trying to get my exercise in and so
this has been a pattern my whole life I
run pretty hard and most of the people I
know run pretty hard and I work out
every day I have a I don't always sleep
well I don't I don't always eat well so
here's the thing
um
I take supplements because I've sat down
and looked at my blood markers and I
know that when I take
I don't know I only almost exclusively
take Thorn stuff I can see the
difference in my blood markers I can
feel it over time of course but
um I can see the difference and I am
playing a long game when it comes to my
health I trust Thorne so much that these
are the supplements the only supplements
I give to my kids and I do it every day
these are supplements I recommend to all
my friends I think half the people in
the booth are on Thorn now
um it's just what I when people ask me
this is I say this is the best this is
who who I who I use and I've been
spending my own money on Thorn
supplements for year after year after my
wife says one day when we can't afford
our kids to go to college that um maybe
Thorne will send them to school because
that's how much money I've sent to them
over the years I also like testing stuff
on myself just n equals one I wonder
what happens if I take this for 60 days
or something like that so um
foreign
I take them on a regular basis I take
them they're important to me and um I
also know there's a lot of garbage out
there so the most common question I get
is what do I take what do I take what do
I take what do I take here are the thorn
products that I take on a daily basis um
and I want to say this with one caveat
if you run out and just buy what I'm
telling you right now
um that's the dumbest thing you could do
because you and I have different bodies
clearly because
um
I was gonna say I'm a smoke show but I'm
not everyone in the booth is like no
you're not
um
I've got different Health priorities
I've got different stressors I've got
different life than you do I've got also
got different genetics than you do I've
got different so don't just run out and
copy everything here which is a common
thing I used to do back in the day
um but I will tell you some a couple
things I think every single grown-up
should be on I'll tell you what I give
to my kids every day
um and then I'll the most important one
is the Sleep
um the things that I've dialed in to
help me with sleep and I'm still messing
with it here and there and then at the
end I'll let you know of a pretty
remarkable
um thing that we're doing for the John
deloney gang the people who listen to
the show all right so here's what I take
um every day of the week
I take
creatine
creatine however you want to say it I
take vitamin D K2
I take fish oil take the Super EPA
B12 grasseton CoQ10 and a few others
here and there but the big ones that I
think every single person should take
creatine
B12 fish oil
vitamin D I think most people should get
that from going outside and living an
outside-ish lifestyle if you don't you
should take vitamin D K2 as well
um and K2 just helps with transport
that's a whole other conversation
um
the rest of these the Q certain the
CoQ10 are things I've dialed in with my
doctor over time
um it just helps with my particular set
of genetics
um Everybody in the booth take something
different but everybody also circles
back to
vitamin D fish oil B vitamins and by the
way I give those to my kids every day I
give my kids fish oil I give my kids B12
and I give one of my kids a half dose of
creatine in the morning
and at night here's the big one helps me
with sleep
I credit
and we can disagree all day long
um I credit over time over about a year
of taking
um
several of these supplements for healing
my anxiety helping me learn to sleep
again and I've tested my sleep with
whoop strap and things like that so
um here's what I take at night
I take full spectrum hemp oil which has
been a game changer for me
um it does not have any THC in it or
anything like that it does have CBD in
it a little bit but it's full spectrum
hemp oil and I credit that with a lot
it's helped over the years now I take it
once or twice a week maybe three times
on a wild week but I don't take it every
day I did for a long time I take Gaba
250
and I take
phosphatidylserine which isofose is as
Thorn does it's an anti-stress which is
pretty incredible and magnesium by
glycinate and I take those with some
almost every night if not every night
and I tell you what my sleep falls off a
cliff in a pretty impressive way
um
they've become an important part of my
overall health routine
um I've got a special cabinet for all
the shenanigans I've got up there I've
started recently messing around with
Thorn they've came out with a powdered
greens product which I like and I've
been taking that and I take a couple
other things here and there just to test
and see what it's doing but over time
here's what I've seen increased
cognitive functioning increased energy
throughout the day
and increase depth and length of my
sleep and those three things being able
to think clearly being able to have some
energy throughout the day and being able
to sleep
um are the three most important factors
of my life and by the way I'll say this
um
there is a number of studies that talk
about the importance of fish oil and B
vitamins when it comes to low-level
depression anxiety other things so those
are definitely conversations to have
with your doctor so here's the deal that
um it's been two years in the making
um I was you notice I don't recommend
supplements on the show which is weird
everyone's always talking supplements
all over the place and I've turned down
a number of opportunities with different
supplement companies because I'm very
particular about what I take and I
wanted to make sure if we're going to do
anything it's going to be what I take at
my house what I give to my kids and
that's thorn
Thorn because they're pure because they
spend money on external testing because
they say they are who they say they are
and by the way in dealing with a company
the people behind the scenes they're
great human beings like they're not
scumbag companies they're not fly by
nights they're in this for the Long Haul
um they're expensive there's no question
about it and so the way supplement
companies usually
um the way they work on podcast is it's
a REV share split right so you buy
something with the code deloni on it and
I get a piece of it and they get a piece
of it the cool part is about Thorn is
they let me set my discount as high as I
want it just cuts out what I make here
and we all met up as a team and I am
much less concerned about making a bunch
of money on this than I am about people
in your home like everyday moms and dads
like you everyday brothers and sisters
and sons and daughters like you
listening to the show who are either
dabbling in supplements for the first
time or who have been just taking crap
for a long time and it's not doing
anything for you
I'm I'm interested in helping you change
your life in the way that me and my
family have been able to do over the
years and I also know that not
everybody's blessed financially just
have a billion dollars to blow on um
supplements all the time so
um here's what we've set up for you if
you go to thorn.com
t-h-o-r-n-e.com slash you the letter u
slash deloni
thorn.com you slash delonia if you're
watching this on YouTube it's in the
lower third and if you listen to this on
podcast there's a link in the show notes
you're going to set up an account which
is going to take three or four minutes
and then you're gonna get 25 off
everything some people like I get free
shipping dude I'm gonna give you 25 off
because it's less about me making money
I've been blessed um y'all have been
supporting the show buying books y'all
been taking care of us and so this is
really our way of taking care of you
guys 25 off everything in your account
that you buy and it's a good way to get
going to help your family get on the
supplement train if you're going to or
to start taking a few supplements that
are of great quality I always recommend
that nobody put anything into their
bodies without checking with their
doctor first if you have a relationship
with your doctor if you're taking other
things if you if you're also taking
other medicines please please don't put
medicine don't put supplements in your
body until you uh meet with your doctor
um
but this is the this is it this is the
big reveal
um this is the conversation about
supplements if you want to go down a
rabbit hole again there's Andrew
huberman there is Peter attia there's
some other folks in the space that are
great resources Lane Norton
um the Mind pump guys we'll talk about
them occasionally there's lots of
discussions out there about why to take
what to take and what it does to you at
the biochemical level
um
that's not what I'm really interested
right now I'm really interested in you
and your family being as well as you
possibly can having energy being able to
sleep and being able to think throughout
the day go to
www.thorn.com you
deloney for 25 off everything